if it does go forward hashtag Tommy aka
Tom Brady becomes a free agent as a
practical matter at 12:01 p.m. Eastern
that's when he can talk to other teams
without it being tampering work out a
deal Exchange offers tentative agreement
etc so Chris summarize for us the turd
you dropped into the Tom Brady punch
bowl on Sunday regarding one of his
potential destinations well listen you
know I've been kind of in the know on
this subject for a few weeks I've had a
lot of talk with all sides connected to
the Tom Brady saga alright yeah I got an
inkling a few weeks ago that the 49ers
were certainly on top of the Tom Brady
wish list right and it makes sense of
course the 49ers are one of the best
teams in football we know that Tom Brady
from San Francisco so if he's looking to
go somewhere else that would have been
the perfect spot for him I understand
that you know but at this time it's hold
on a second is it breaking up should I
slow down here should I start this over
you're fine I hear you fine keep going
okay good I just want to make sure I saw
my face on FaceTime here and it was
starting to get a little choppy there
but you know I think that yes I found
out this weekend that that that was not
going to happen now you know I know you
wrote on the headline 45 Niners say no
to Tom Brady hey listen I'm not so sure
they said no the Tom Brady but I
certainly would think yes that's what
happened more more or not I'm assuming
that because I did have the knowledge
that Brady was you know hot on the 49ers
so there's a lot of things that go into
this you know to me the big thing is
what is the market for Tom Brady right
now right you know I do think the 49ers
we're in the mix here for a little bit
but there's a lot of things on the 49ers
end I think that people have to realize
goes into this conversation too you know
the time you know if you're going to
sign the Tom Brady and you're the San
Francisco 49ers okay you within doing
that you're also going to have to find a
trade partner for Jimmy Garoppolo right
and you know I just don't know how far
those
discussions went but you're certainly
not just going to go oh we're signing
Tom Brady and we're gonna let Jimmy
Garoppolo go out the door for nothing a
guy who you paid a lot of money to and
just brought you to the Super Bowl so
there's a lot of different moving parts
there to why it didn't work I don't
really know why it didn't work but I
know nonetheless it's dead and it's not
happening and now the big question is
yes where is the market for Tom Brady I
know the Tampa Bay Buccaneers are
interested in Brady I don't know what
Brady's feel is for the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers and then of course is there
another team out there that we just
don't know about or at least I don't
know about now let me back up a step
right because if the 49ers truly view
Tom Brady is an upgrade to Jimmy
Garoppolo why do you have to have a
specific plan in place for what you're
going to do with Garoppolo other than to
not have Garoppolo and Brady on the
roster at the same time both consuming
huge cap charges I mean you want to get
Garoppolo off before you get Brady on
you could agree to wait a while to
finalize the Brady deal to do something
with Garoppolo but you have until April
1 to pull the plug on Garoppolo uh and
and avoid any guarantees for 2020 I just
think that if you decide Brady's your
guy you deal with Garoppolo separately
it I think the end result here is they
looked at it they studied it they
considered it they thought about it and
they decided Garoppolo is their guy not
Tom Brady I think that's fair you know I
don't know the answer to that but me
just being in football my whole life and
knowing you know people I know
throughout the league and things too you
know I think you're spot on there I
think the other thing too you know take
into account here is you know okay if
you're if you do think Brady's the guy
are great you know still you might only
have one year with them right and
there's some risk in that alone let
alone to let a guy like Jimmy Garoppolo
just you know go for free or maybe not
the price you asked for and we know he's
kind of just starting or hitting the
prime of his career where he's playing
and getting used to the NFL and getting
real reps so I think that has to be
taken to it account to you know you're
only going to get Brady for one or
two years two years at the most here I
think and to just sell Jimmy Garoppolo
down the road and say all hey see ya
later it doesn't matter we got Tom Brady
he's better right now and we want him I
just don't think it's as easy as that
and to what you said to push it off I
mean as we know these this information
always gets out right which would then
lower the value of maybe a trade Jimmy
Garoppolo guy and then also it's hard to
go further along in your free agency and
draft proceedings a little bit because
you don't know how things are going to
shake out there too so again I know it's
an interesting topic but I think at the
end of the day the 49ers realized they
were better off with Jimmy Garoppolo
they're going forward with him so what
is it down to then for Tom Brady I saw a
chef teah last night on Twitter with a
clip from SportsCenter saying that it
doesn't look like he's going back to the
Patriots and we're getting to the point
where teams that have been laying in
wait can make a run for Tom Brady well
we've heard from time to time teams that
may be interested but as of right now
Chris and as you said yesterday it looks
like it's just the Buccaneers and the
Patriots who else is out there that that
we should be thinking about that maybe
we aren't yeah right I mean you know and
and I have no feel or inside knowledge
about how much Brady loves the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers like I said you know that
they are interested in him then like
answer your question Michael I mean
let's go down like you know hey the
Miami Dolphins I know there's a lot of
connections there I just don't see that
happening
I don't think Brady you know at 43 is
gonna go let's be part of a rebuild year
and we'll go win it is 44 years old I
don't think that happens with the
Oakland Raiders either so to me the only
other team left out there right now with
Tennessee being out of the mix and going
all-in on Ryan Tannehill is the Chargers
I have no knowledge of anything that's
going on there with the Chargers but
there's a lot of people around the
league that are murmuring that that
could be a real thing so I am hearing
that but I don't know anybody in the
know to definitively tell me that yeah
and
I mean we've spit bald on every team
possible I've I've suggested hey maybe
at some point Jerry Jones is gonna
become exasperated with dak Prescott and
decide he'll go after Tom Brady instead
the Cowboys by the way as expected have
applied the exclusive franchise tag to
dak Prescott they could trade him I
assume if they would if they would wake
up and say we just don't want to sign
this guy to a long-term deal on his
terms but that's not looking lightly I
mean our I mean that's not looking
likely I look around though and it's
Buccaneers Chargers maybe the Raiders
maybe the Dolphins but I mean if he
wants to win now Chris and we're not
have an off season program and I don't
think we are there's only one place
where you can say he's got a likelihood
of winning and that's staying where he
is assuming where he is wants him yeah
uh yeah I mean you're right that's the
the the least risky decision out of the
one out of all of the above I mean you
know you don't have some weapons if you
went to Tampa Bay certainly but man he's
gonna have to learn a new Bruce Arians
offense and he's gonna have to stand in
the pocket for six and seven seconds to
get crushed to throw the ball down the
field you know is he gonna relocate his
family to Tampa Bay I don't know you
know the Chargers I in theory makes
sense I mean there are a team that I
don't think is far off their defenses we
both know the top five defenses so far
and they do have some weapons on the
offensive side of the ball and you've
been pounding the table forever about
they need you know some billboard
material in LA so I get that the the
thing I find most interesting about what
sheffy said yesterday and again
Scheckter is I got the ultimate respect
to him he was doing that report on ESPN
yesterday with the Michigan helmet
behind him and a Tom Brady figurine
behind him okay I mean to me that gut is
like hey sort of different I might know
something I don't know okay and then
within that the biggest thing I took
from what he said yesterday is why does
anybody think a deal is going to happen
with the New England Patriots and I
think that's the big thing right now do
the do the Patriots one of
they're giving signals right now that
they're certainly not like oh man we got
to sign Tom right now or you know we're
ruling for 2020 they're not doing that
they certainly don't seem panicked and
we don't really have a feel for how they
feel about having Tom Brady back or not
and I just don't know where that goes
you know I've seen a few times this
weekend that Shakespeare wrote King Lear
while he was quarantined during the
plague
it is almost Shakespearean when you
think about Brady Bill Belichick Robert
Kraft Robert Kraft does not want this
sticking to him if Brady leaves but it
could be that at the end of the day
Brady realizes I'm better off staying
with the Patriots and Bill it's belcheck
saying oh I I think he's gonna leave
what do I do now right and who's gonna
take the blame and at what point do they
start spinning it as Tom Brady's decided
under the circumstances under these
broader world circumstances and the
likelihood of no offseason program that
he should stay with the Patriots how
does that get spun by the Patriots if
Brady starts banging the drum of we
should stay together for one more year
given everything that's going on oh
that's where I think that the Patriots
will be in a tough spot if that was the
case to where I'm not so sure they
wouldn't succumb to public pressure and
just go forth with Tom Brady if that be
the case is I think mr. Kraft would
certainly you know back Brady in that to
say let's get it done but I do think if
that does happen then New England also
knows okay
Brady is not hot on any other teams and
they're gonna force him to take a
contract that they want that's the one
thing I say that will happen I mean
again just my experience of following
Bill Belichick all these years and being
up there in New England he just it just
doesn't matter who you are you know
he'll give you hugs and tell you how
great you are once you retire but as
long as you're in this business it's
just there's no free flower bouquets or
anything like that
there's no gonna be like oh no pat on
the back I respect you I love you I'm
going to show you all this respect he's
going to continue to treat it like in
business even with the goat I don't
think he's gonna Bend in that fashion
and I think one of the real
of living in times like this you strip
away all of the crap the ego goes out
the window and you focus on what's
important and if it's important to him
to try to get Superbowl number seven
before he retires he needs to realize
and Belichick needs to realize this as
well their best chance comes from
staying together comes from continuity
if the offseason program is going to be
gone if there's a chance training camp
will be curtailed right if there's any
chance that this is gonna affect the
strategic objectives of the Patriots and
it makes it better and smarter for them
to have Tom Brady than to have Jared
Stidham or someone else
belcheck is going to decide to do right
so I think the events of the past few
days make it more likely that he stays
notwithstanding anything that chef teah
said with his Michigan helmet as Tom
Brady action figure on the shelf behind
him
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports